rolling stone has provoked some outrage
this
week with um a new cover that which is
uh the harry styles cover and as you can
see the outrage it's not because he
looks incredibly
stupid he's got i don't know what he's
got some kind of
uh boxers on in a fur coat
holding a birthday cake
and anyway it says harry styles
how the new king of pop
set the music world aflame
and that's what upsets people is that he
says that's king of pop
and this is a controversy now because
it's it's appropriating from michael
jackson so newsweek has
the report says harry styles has
inadvertently upset passionate michael
jackson fans after a magazine referred
to him as the new king of pop
jackson's fans and even his nephew taj
jackson voiced their displeasure at
stiles's new apparent title the october
november issue of rolling stone uk
magazine features a former one direction
singer styles on the front cover where
he's awarded his new royal title
uh but people are very upset about that
thousands upon thousands of jackson fans
spoke out on twitter
quote there is no new king of pop you
don't own the title rolling stone and
you didn't earn it my uncle did michael
jackson's nephew taj wrote on twitter
retweeting the cover shoot decades of
dedication and sacrifice this title has
been retired no disrespect to harry
styles he's mega talented give him his
own unique title
community actress uh yvette nicole brown
weighed in
and says
um
agrees with that and then a bunch of
other people okay whatever people are
upset a bunch of michael jackson fans
are very upset about this because
michael jackson is the king of pot pop
just two things i want to point out here
first of all
michael jackson was a pedophile
so he doesn't deserve to retain any
titles at all
okay so that just getting offended on
his behalf he's a dead pedophile
and so
we take away all his titles
i mean we we rip down monuments left and
right
and we're ripping down monuments taking
the founding fathers names off of school
buildings and everything else
and yet we're still worried about
protecting the good name of a monstrous
freak pedophile
here's the thing about michael jackson
there was nothing good about him
but he could dance that's it he just he
was a good dancer
and he made some songs that were kind of
catchy i'll give him that
um
and then he also raped children so
i i'm not sure how i see the the good
the good dancing outweighs the raping of
children
and on top of that he was just a freak
so
if we're look
if we were deciding as a society to just
sort of leave history alone
and uh and not rip down the monuments
and statues and everything like that
then maybe i would say that yeah michael
jackson was a pedophile freak and a
child abuser but uh okay he was awarded
the title king of pop and sure he can
keep it because that's
but
we can't have it both ways here
like if we're going back in history and
we're we we are um
taking superlatives away from people and
reevaluating them and and taking away
their honorifics
because of the bad things they did then
i'm not sure how we
gloss over michael jackson
second point though is that i actually
agree that harry styles is not the king
of pop um
you know i i've never even heard a harry
styles song i don't think i don't think
i've ever i couldn't i certainly
couldn't name for you one harry styles
song i couldn't tell you if i heard if i
heard of him singing i wouldn't be able
to tell you that it was him
um because even though he's
massively successful and famous and
millions of people
have
heard his music apparently he doesn't
have the kind of cultural impact that
michael jackson did have
um or that elvis had before
and that's just because that's the
culture we live in now it's just not
it's not possible for anyone to have
that kind of impact anymore
everything is just sort of fractured
into a million pieces and there are a
million celebrities it's like anyone and
fame is so cheap now anyone can be
famous anyone can make something and and
put it out there and and you know
millions of people will encounter it
there are um
you know i was very happy when i crossed
a million subscribers on youtube it's a
big accomplishment for me there are
youtube channels out there with a
hundred
million subscribers
like 50 million 100 million
and then you go and you check out those
channels
and there's
there's nothing there like there are
channels where they
all they do is reactions and so
they watch other people's videos and
they don't say anything interesting
about them they don't riff on them in an
interesting way they don't say anything
they just watch someone else's video and
then maybe they go that's wild
and that'll get 50 million views and
they say 100 million dollars like a
multi-millionaire is doing that
that's how cheap fame is and also and
also how splintered and fractured it is
so you can have someone with like
hundreds of millions of fans and yet
outside of that bubble no one even has
even heard of that person
so that's the world we live in now and
that's part of the reason why
there actually will never be
another king of pop
so i say that in in a certain way in you
know in defense of the critics here
although still michael jackson's a child
raping pedophile so
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there